well that went horribly or well we have
no idea you have 9001 but we do know how
to win we're gonna tell one than the in
the next one yeah keep that I don't do
second thing so what we're gonna do now
is reach going to come up with our own
action do it backwards and see who can
guess what we were doing and whoever
guesses it it's like a sure you'll get
100,000 subscribers
[Music]
getting married okay I got it
your buddies put you in chair for the
blindfold on you know you okay okay my
turn my turn I'm a person what they're
oh you're you like a celebrity mmm
I guess you could say that he was
Mathias dyeing his hair
take that and rewind it back
[Music]
Hunter that killed his prey and then
cooked it yeah Wow
this is gonna be really tough to do yeah
I need a knight okay let's break this
down he was like booj then he was like
sliding he was mark getting but you can
click that clip to get over to their
trip
I guess yours exactly right so we both
get and I get yours exactly right no
heat no that was me we've all tallied up
points out okay but but that was legit
well done yeah that was pretty good
because I broke it down right yes yeah
[Music]
that was yes Jean white snowboarding yes
come on up here see that reverse I know
I wish I was in the kitchen yeah work me
how many subscribers
oh man you made me forget what I was
gonna do upswing rewind that wait what
are we talking about I did
okay all right we're all done here this
was a bunch of [ __ ] and I'm pretty
sure everyone's gonna forget we ever did
this one so but thank you everybody for
being here who's one walk lasted so I
hope you enjoyed it - do you want to see
another video that we did over on Team
edges channel you can check out the link
in the description below or the fancy
new annotation thing over there have you
got the new annotation system and
they're available on desktop and mobile
you can click through anywhere it's
beautiful it's very beautiful
so anyway click on that when it cure
them 20 seconds to the end it was a
little difficult dudes bored anyway I
can get everybody so much for watching
and that's all
[Music]